it feels good to tell people what to do
no I I believe that a lot of the people
who are the self-appointed enforcers of
what we are and are not allowed to say
they think they're they're motivated by
virtue they do I'm going but I think the
thrill of it isn't the thrill of doing
good
I think the thrill of it is
authoritarian that you're pushing other
people around you're punishing them when
they get out of line it's it's all about
power and you can Anza sysm plays a
certain aspect of it that's for instance
with the Roger Scruton affair when
George Eaton essentially helped to get
Roger Scruton fired he put a post on
Instagram with himself swinging a bottle
of champagne saying that I'm quoted
almost probably quite a bit essentially
said that feeling you get when you get a
racist sect yeah well I mean that's a
good example
he'd bagged a trophy this is it's at
this is actually a predatory sport and
getting people sacked it is now one of
the things that you do on social media
and and even now because that was the
New Statesman in mainstream media I
thought that was especially unseemly I
it it did it it surprised me that that
happened at the New Statesman it's
interesting you say and what Francis
says because I know that I like Peter
game sometimes and that feeling where
you have the ability to type something
into your own little computer and a
human being on the other end of that
communication does something different
or something happens you know you get
even on this platform twitch which is
where you watch other people play
computer games
yes I'm very sad I said there's a
platform that exists how I know that's a
yes I guess that means that that for the
that audience the paint has already
dried and so one of the things that
happens and you're not gonna believe
this is they find out where that person
lives who's streaming this game
themselves and they get a SWAT team they
complain about them saying there's some
kind of terrorist activity happening in
that that address and they get SWAT team
to come in and knock the door down and
arrest them or take them into custody
while it's happening there is that level
of oh if I do this here then that thing
happens over there and you think that
that is what's happening with these
twitch twitch fork mobs the Twitter mobs
where essentially it's about power it's
about totally about power and the
exercise of power and one things but
it's interesting in the young adult
fiction area which has gone particularly
the nuts I don't I don't I don't
understand why but a number of the the
writers on some of these platforms who
have been the most vociferous the most
censorious the most predatory have also
been converted to pray when they publish
their own work and and you know they've
got a character who is gay and they're
not gay or something like that and and
then they end up suffering from the the
same mass attack that they had been
organizing against other people there's
a certain rough justice in that there
are some people particularly people who
are against that kind of ideology who
rubbed their hands and glee at this and
go well look at the left is eating
itself and whatever and and I thought
worries me because I think in a way
we're all eating ourselves when that
happens do you know I mean I don't think
it's healthy when I don't think he's
helping one that happens to anyone know
it is I mean I say there that there are
some rough justice in that but it we it
would be better if we were not living in
a world that this was happening at all
and I'm concerned that this whole pile
on mentality is infecting major
institutions it's possible I'll write my
column about this this coming weekend
but the best example I can think of is
what happened this week at Harvard where
one of the professors at the Law School
very distinguished
I think he's a Dean was part of the team
who represented Harvey Weinstein and the
students got up in arms and the
administration backed down and and
sacked him and this is completely
contrary to the principles of law I mean
this should have been a what do they
call it a teaching moment it's like
sorry but no matter how perfidious a
character may be everyone is deserving
of legal representation
and just because you represent someone
legally that doesn't you know what they
did is not supposed to rub rub off on
you you know that there's a just because
you represent someone you're not
responsible for what they did or didn't
do that's the way the legal system works
and yet just a bunch of students saying
they were uncomfortable or and felt
unsafe and I'm just all this nonsense
all this uh Turley in it's insincere
crap and we could get to that in a
moment
the Harvard caved Harvard Harvard so the
worry is not so much social media you
know if it's
- Twitter etc it's painful it's gross
it's impolite and it's cutthroat but the
implications are limited they're no
longer limited where we are now in a mob
rule universe and across-the-board
mainstream institutions are caving to
the pressure of the crowd and and
throwing principal out the window
[Music]